[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
bleacher reports
pregame picks the only show in the world
where you
the people at home get to win free cash
prizes by simply predicting the random
[ __ ] that occurs
in the nba pregame tonight we are live
from portland
where the trail trailblazers versus the
boston celtics we got a lot of money to
give away
and you already know what's going on so
let's get to these
pics baby
let's get it boom i told you how crazy
is that wait is that a three let's see
that's a three that's a three step curry
wow my name i told y'all welcome to
pregame picks
let's get it
hey what's cracking y'all as always we
are back
i'm your host pierre aka p with the plug
and i'm joined
as always by my brother from another
famous lost
lois was cracking with you brody
what's up bro we back man we're back in
action what's cracking
hey listen as always we got plenty to
get to but i will let the people know
that while production was counting me
into the show to do the intro
you damn they had me in tears i damn
near messed the intro up cause of that
last thing you just sent me on ig
you are hilarious hey if you don't
follow lots on instagram
please do please do yes because i damn
near messed up the intro to the show
because of this man tell me you got a
girlfriend without telling me you got a
girlfriend don't comment on that last
video if you're watching
go comment on that last video yeah
please go comment
belows we starting off today's show
with a question who would be the ideal
superstar
to team up with damian lillard all y'all
at home let me know in the comments
what superstar y'all want to see damian
lillard with lois which
i know you got a great answer for me so
let me know
who is it going to be because i got my
ass i don't know why
but the first thing just can't look at
look at tya's little brother look at
look at uh tyus
ty jones little brother trey y'all seen
him
but um uh kawhi leonard
that's trey jones look at trey jones
i don't know why i don't know why but
that's the first name that came to mind
came to my mind when you said that you
said teaming up with
damn dane coming off [ __ ] hitting them
threes he needed somebody like hawaii
defender uh he don't won before
he you know a bit he that uh cj cj it
but
see it's not going to rebound i don't
mean to cut you off bro
but we got somebody saying spencer
dinwiddie i can't pronounce his first
name but i start with a g
perry i'm going to call him g perry he
says yeah how are you feeling about that
yeah i i needed it i needed it to get
warmed up and get ready going cause
somebody dumb as hell who said that man
who how the hell did they go
hey listen
spencer is my dog too but that was a
wild ass that was a wild ass answer
we know so nice we know spencer nice we
know he's nice as hell
but come on man that ain't gonna be the
right way superstar
hey i'm rocking with a.d
ain't gonna work tell me why it ain't
gonna work no no no
i mean it'll be it'll work it'll be good
it's a good it'll be a good team because
a.d can fit anywhere
uh pause but it ain't gonna it's not a
superstar like win
like i don't i don't hear them two
together just say oh
winning like they won they winning
unless
cj stayed the cj state is scary if she
just stays there
i'm saying a.d is because i'm kind of
tired of seeing dame
with a like a another perimeter player
with him i want to see you with him with
a big man
who can scream yeah that's why i said
kawhi that's why i said kauai
kawhi because kawhi is a little
different kawhi is different than cj
he is he is but kawaii still going to
play on the perimeter
a d can play on the perimeter but he
gonna be inside and
defensively he gonna protect the rim but
defensively kawaii kawaii gonna take the
best assignment
he's gonna take and this is no
disrespect for cedar kawaii and kawaii
gonna say and kawaii gonna play in the
post he can play back to paul
he can play back the basket too and they
already got cantor
and oh boy rebound they got they got
they got rim protectors they got real
protectors and rebounders
what if i said
oh my god oh my god
oh he's nice as hell he nice as hell who
is this
hey go go go give us some go and give us
a breakdown with the big bank
he tried to get in this big big bag he
must know we watching
you see that that's that wrap around
like that that big that
uh hey see he know we watching now but
he still got it on that road
hey look at that back up look at that
back up he really liked that he really
liked it
he walking the dog he walking hey hey
listen though
i i bet i bet if he take a shot he
missed
let's see if he got another joke look i
was not hitting shoot that
really anyway though yeah that ain't
nothing though he ain't shoot different
real anyway
if he stood up tonight he might go for
16.
i bet 50 jumping jacks if he takes a
shot
which he might not that he missed yeah
really watch this young boy handle
though i'm really surprised because he
really
he really handling their rock like that
though he oh my god that's why he's
trying to dribble he
he don't want to shoot he don't want to
shoot but hey let's get to the first
prompt of the day
for the people at home that's trying to
win some money i know what y'all came
for
will damian lillard make seven shots in
a row
during warm-ups yes or no loss
guide the people what you got to tell
the people for that
hey when we did when we did this with
steph what was it
what was it he made uh it was where what
was the number was it seven
will he make 12. i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm
sorry no
he was supposed to make seven but he
only made five in a row
oh so now we don't dang if steph can't
do it dave ain't gonna do it
damn look look pan says pants take you
to the mother
um chill
dame is a little bit more focused who's
she texting her
hey her man he like don't you say
nothing to damien a little
how you get how she get them tickets hey
why my phone why my phone go pink
hey you got your lady at home you better
chill
who who is coming out the touch that's a
little bit oh he's coming
they will make seven in a row i i'm
rocking with you too they ain't making
seven in a row
we got dame coming out of the tunnel
let's get the cameras on dame i need
seven in a row from the get-go
steph curry took a little too long he
was playing games
my boy game he focused look at him he
ready
name already made he already made five
in a row
he made five walking in
can we get one up there then he made
that layer okay cool
okay cool we got we got it right dave
i'm gonna
get right there what are they playing
i'm gonna look through some of these hey
i want to i want to give a shout out to
my boy
once my boy juan said
for the last question we asked he said
envy to be the best teammate for damn he
said dane would keep that lane so clear
for him
with the range that he has shout out to
my boy once
as a matter of fact let's send one some
money can we do that production
can we still do that can we send one
some money
that was yeah i like saying i like
sending him some money but he's wrong as
hell
he hey i like his answer because it's a
post player we haven't seen
dane with a post player as dominant as
joel embiid
so that's the do you like his answer or
spencer didn't wait
spencer whoever said spencer then we
literally should slap their damn self
hey once check yours check your dms
on the bleacher report app after this
we're going to send you 200
uh because i like your comment look at
jalen brown over there trying to test
the balls
ain't nothing wrong with them
basketballs man damian lillard already
got three in a row
though hey you remember hey you know hey
we're in the new generation you got to
pause that [ __ ]
trying to test the balls you gotta say
pause bro no no
no comment no comment no comment yeah
this this is
going to say testing you can't say test
the ball no cards
no more but that i mean that's what he
doing but he he missed
he missed though he's back
i like him i like him what was that
money that boy had nappy as hell
[Laughter]
i was gonna ask you since you like paid
what the hell is in ronnie hollis
jefferson head
this he doesn't want to make the last
chance to get inspired
no man i like the damn rappers but come
on man nah then we're at football man
hey chap chap what the hell are you
doing chap
hey hey comments let me know who got the
wildest hairstyle in the nba in the
comments let us know but what i was
going to ask you bro
who is your favorite rookie outside of
lamello
and anthony edwards damn because
obviously everybody liked the top two
but you said you like peyton
who else you like i ain't gonna lie that
what anthony was he really i'm really
sold
i'm gonna because in the future i know
it's gonna be really different
but yeah i'm sold but um
oh oh boy from um sacramento he got a
weird game to me
but he's nice as hell
allah hey shout out my boy
my boy curl2152 i'm looking through the
comments on my phone
he say damn going for show hit that
seven in a row shout out to curl215
cause he was on the last show shot
that's that's our family from um
that that's my family from from philly
he's from philly
somebody's gonna make 12. somebody said
daniel made 12
hell no i i don't know about that we
just trying to get seven we don't even
need him to do too much that's four in a
row
that's four in a row um i'm trying to
think of some rookies i like what about
my boy emmanuel quickly
you know i'm a you know i'm a knicks fan
you ain't got no love for you man you're
quick oh my god hey
oh my god hey nice be nice yeah yeah
yeah nice hey nice matter of fact i
might maybe quickly first
matter of fact you really gotta throw
some names out there so i can hear him
so i can really think about that think
about what the hell i'm saying you feel
me
but quickly like oh wow oh wow
no he didn't bro no he did it damn
he did not just do it y'all damn gone
y'all
look at mellow a whole damn bucket no no
he didn't bro
no he didn't bro there's no way in hell
yeah
he just walked off with four shots made
what is up with this yeah hey hey can we
change
it this is the only thing yeah but it's
the only thing
he's they're doing they're doing layups
and [ __ ] right now
dame is about to come could die that boy
draw like a whole damn 50 piece
but but listen though i want to make a
compatible
i want to make it audible let's put it
on mellow let's change it can we do cj
now can we do somebody that's on the
floor nah
hey no no cause when listen when dame
come back
it's gonna be individual shooting it's
not gonna be just
a layup line shooting so when it comes
back okay so just keep getting the ball
back
you think dame coming back in the next
nine minutes that's what you're telling
me
he better who they playing again
balls they play at jt all right hey hey
i got an oliver they told me to pick an
item but those who are we going with if
we going with
carmelo or cj mccullough
let's go with cj but let's go with cj
if daniel come back remember damn got fo
all right if dan come back remember he
got four everybody in the comments
we rolling with cj can cj make seven
shots in a row
please get us a camera ain't going cj so
we can track these shots because
for all we know he might have made seven
already or six
that might have just been his seventh
week right there
all right game is back game is back i'm
sorry i'm sorry damon's back
shoes we need three more shots come on
dame
give us three more mix give us three
more mix baby
taco fall what up ball head
what taco damn taco dark is that damn
mask
shout out my boy taco bear hey how you
think the celtics gonna do in the
playoffs the celtics haven't kind of
they kind of having a down year man they
the seventh seed out in the east i
couldn't predict that
that's cause they don't play taco
that's five on the road so taco taco
taco why they don't play hey why they
don't play taco he's shooting free
throws so it's about to be seven
that's hey six in a row hold up let's
go with seven seven free throw
let's go there you go
[Applause]
i'm for the people hey we i hope
it's a way that we can rig it so my boy
curly215 from philly who then tuned in
to multiple episodes i hope i hope you i
hope you get some money because you did
say he was going to make seven in a row
for show
so i hope you get some money uh
he did yeah he get you right we gave him
money for the no that one him that was
ones
curly need to win some money off this i
want him to be one of the five people
that take five hundred dollars home for
the seven makes
and then last but not least
we got blazers last shot whether it be a
dunk
or a layup or a jumper
the dunkin layup is together it's gonna
be a dunker layout the dunk it
it's gonna be a knuckle i lay up all
right i just had to be rolling with jump
shots yeah i don't know why i just had a
video
what did you think hey what you think
that ain't going for tonight
uh hey let's make a bet you ain't trying
to bet
why you think of our bet let me shout
out our winner shout out to justin hans
shout out to jesse shout out to who is
i don't know moisey i don't i shout out
to mr iblee lion blue you a lions fan
i'm from chicago no damn lions fans
winning on money
shout out to raider 909 hey take back mr
i bleed lion blue take his money back
no damn lions fan stop playing with that
i'm a cowboys fan but still
all right so back to damian lillard how
much are you going so this
this is for 50 jumping jacks i i think
damien
is going to drop 43.
yeah he gonna go for something like that
because steph went crazy last night
you know they ain't got something to get
steph for some reason every time steph
go for 80.
they ain't gonna come back and have
savage
jason tatum son on the team you ain't
seen him you gonna see him
taco they put the taco put the put the
camera back on jason tatum son
if y'all can they got jason tatum's son
in a layup line with him
but there's no way taco and right there
that's jason
jason tatum son got a warm up he got a
warm up
he got a jersey warm-up they got him
like he on the team
hey that's a whole bucket jeremiah nice
as hell
no no yeah yeah yeah yeah i'm just
talking [ __ ] and lsu trump
was oh yeah definitely a walking bucket
no no question
oh yeah he liked that but he liked that
for real i
i just found it funny that they got
three people that look like jason say
that go
that small jason tatum that's medium
jason tatum grant williams and then they
got actual large jason tatum
at the end they got three versions of
jason tatum the balls and celtics
why don't they play tremont
i don't know kimbo you got to go from
kimber to who
who they go from kim madoo peyton
pritchard a rookie that you like from
oregon
i like him too but you're not different
man
tremaine is a bucket now he's a big time
bugger and he got some clutch buckets
out
you ain't telling me
are the celtics good enough to upset
somebody in the playoffs
yeah they're good somebody jb address
like 20-fold
and damn jt is jt hell yeah they can do
it
[ __ ] it don't look like it matter to
they the seventh seed
so if they get who the second say no is
the second seed that's
i know that no this is a league
i know i'm just saying this the league
so they just gotta keep getting rolling
if they become if they get in like the
sixth seed
they're gonna play somebody and the
sixes and all them
sixes are [ __ ] nice but the sixers can
get beat bro they just
they been known they ain't no they ain't
known just for going to the
oh finals there and don't forget don't
forget the play-in tournament they got
to play in if they stay at the seventh
seed
but if the men started today
the celtics have to play against the
celtics i mean
against the nets in a seven game series
how many games can the celtics win in a
series against brooklyn
tell me that two three two three
damn you giving them three
damn i don't i i brooklyn don't really
give me a reason just to trust
them like that do they get you
they don't but they do cause james
harden kyrie and kevin durant that's a
three-head monster we never seen
i yeah no i love it i love it but i'm
just thinking in the real
world since they do lose in the in the
fake world if we're just looking at the
rosters they never lose
but in the real world they they lose
some time
it's hard for me to throw all my bread
with them i actually don't know who they
are gonna win bro
if i had to put my money on anybody to
win it i just gotta go with damn braun
cause braun won last year no
we're going with the clippers but since
you're so high on jaylen brown and jason
tatum
give me a breakdown of jaylen brown
right now we got a camera on jaylen
brown give me this breakdown right now
break down his game for me while we got
the camera on him look don't
no look the thing the thing i hate about
jaylen brown because he's stupid sleppo
even though he's averaging 24 so it's
like what is this dream that he's doing
what is he doing right now why is he
dribbling in a circle tell me what is
that working on
he's it he's just dribbling most of it
first of all most of his like he just
dribbled on the outside with the outside
hand
he just dripping on the outside hand
going around bone saying we need to go
in put another
other hand you know how you dribble a
line you know how you dribble the line
it looked like he was doing that or he
was just [ __ ] and just dribbling
around
but anyway uh he don't get no credit for
it he'll get no credit for the
movies.com back he got
uh jaylen got the stupid handle his
handle don't get
no love like he get like he got the dumb
handle
and he could play back the back he could
play back to the basket
he got bounced but you know who he got
you know where he got that from you know
who he was working with
the last couple of summers he was
working with a scoring legend
no not me i ain't a scoring legend not
even cold
think think think what was it magic
tracy oh jason tatum was working with
jason
taylor was working with code
[Applause]
i think i i think i think i got i got a
t i got a t-max somewhere over here
i'm trying to find where teammate gets
who he was working with t-bag
yeah adidas family we got oh yeah okay
oh yeah t-man like oh boy that jersey
right there
come on man hey we got people we got 50
seconds let's go
what what's up we got 50 seconds all
right
all right team me up here we go i'm
gonna take this hat this about to go
down i'm gonna give you a live
play-by-play breakdown that's how i do
it that's how i call it a game
so hey where did we go first though we
went with leia right we went with leo
you said layup i got i got a jump shot
you said layup i know somebody gonna
shoot it like break it down break it
down
break it down i know it's going through
so what's about to happen right now is
we got everybody taking these shots
we we go about a clock so what's going
to happen is
somebody is going to try to lay it up to
end it with a layup or a dunk but you're
going to have one of these young guys
out here anthony simons
damien little you see him back there by
the logo he literally waiting for the
clock to go down
to shoot down three two
one it was a lot what i say
what i say baby what i say hey look
hey oh god i was staring that dude
open real i was staring over dude put
that layer up he put the layup up
look a second too late shout out to my
boy for lagging
i told you i hope y'all win what i told
y'all look at that look
look and it was cash money cash money my
family yeah
he made a lot of cash in the morning i
got a
hey so we got five people that's going
home
with two hundred dollars to end the show
we gave away 500 we gave away 200 we
gave away another 200 to my boy juans in
the comments
as always why don't people watch us
we giving away money loss who don't want
free money hey if you was on this show
if you was on this show today you won
you came up today i'm trying to figure
out why is everybody not tuned in
everybody tune in next time everybody
tune in
if you want some money check your dms on
the beach report app
lots you know it's always love my
brother he hit that [ __ ]
okay hey remember daddy gonna have 40
son tonight
they ain't gonna have 40 some people
them jumping jacks
hey shout out to winners man shout out
to winners
[Applause]
baby
[Music]
[Music]
you